nach langem tauziehen haben sich
großbritannien und der eu auf einem
brett vertrag verständigt
dies gaben der britische premier johnson
und eu-kommissionspräsident juncker am
mittag bekannt nun soll auch der eu
gipfel der gerade in brüssel läuft dem
zustimmen allerdings schaut es eben
großbritannien nicht nach einer mehrheit
für den kompromiss aus
ein händedruck der chefs ein foto mit
den unterhändlern so sieht es aus wenn
briten und europäer die
scheidungspapiere einreichen
wir haben eine vereinbarung und die
bedeutet haben wir haben keinen grund
den drag city netze landespolitisch der
kompromiss ist angeblich das beste aus
zwei welten in nordirland gelten weiter
eu waren standards aber es gibt keine
grenzkontrollen auf der insel durch eine
zoll partnerschaft profitierte von
britischen handelsverträgen aber es
erhebt weiter zelle im namen der eu
nordirlands parlament kann das alles
nach vier jahren kippen die eu darf
antworten mit neuen maßnahmen zum schutz
des binnenmarkts den decks dorf
abgeräumt den binnenmarkt geschützt gute
laune auf dem gipfel und doch skepsis ob
das durchgeht deshalb die unsere
zwischen haid ist gepaart mit
berechtigter vorsicht denn die
geschichte leer durch dass die
parlamente noch nein sagen können ich
hoffe jetzt sehr dass sich unsere
abgeordneten in westminster einigen um
den exit angeschlossen
die fragen schon auf sie ein und nur mit
hilfe des lieben freund buch ist kein
jean claude juncker nachschieben
naja ich freue mich über die
vereinbarung aber ich bin traurig über
den dreck cid
wir haben einen deal
die frage ist was wetter am ende aus ihm
zugeschaltet unsere korrespondenten in
london und brüssel anne gellinek wer hat
sich jetzt mehr bewegt die eu oder
johnson
der vertrag ist ein klassischer
kompromiss der versucht die roten linien
beider seiten irgendwie unter einen hut
zu bringen
die briten haben die einigung möglich
gemacht indem sie sich der idee einer
zoll partnerschaft mit der eu für
nordirland geöffnet haben und die eu hat
die kröte geschluckt dass die nordiren
faktisch ein veto haben über die praxis
regeln in nordirland alle staats und
regierungschefs die heute hier beim
gipfel eingetroffen sind zeigten sich
erleichtert darüber dass es ein abkommen
gibt und übten sich in zweckoptimismus
man vertraue boris johnson dass er das
abkommen irgendwie durch britische
parlament boxen werde dass das nicht
dass die eu-seite sich allerdings auch
sorgen macht das wurde bei der
pressebegegnung von boris johnson mit
jung chang claude juncker deutlich
juncker richtete eine warnung direkt ins
britische parlament und sagte dies ist
der letzte deal und die letzte
möglichkeit am 31 oktober fristgerechte
auszutreten
eine verlängerung wird es eu von eu
seite nicht mehr geben und das ist eine
ganz klare ansage auch an london dort
muss ja das unterhaus dem vertrag am
samstag zustimmen diana zimmermann wie
wahrscheinlich ist das denn
fifty-fifty würde ich sagen und auch
wenn jean claude juncker diese
verlängerung ich möchte so ist sie doch
immer noch möglich auch das würde ich
sagen alle anderen prognosen an dieser
stelle sind wirklich waghalsig boris
johnson hat keine eigene mehrheit
im britischen parlament die nordirischen
unionisten die seine regierung
eigentlich stützen sollten haben gesagt
sie werden für diesen deal nicht stimmen
außerdem müsste er die 21 konservativen
abgeordneten die er selbst aus der
partei geschmissen hat weil sie gegen
ihn gestimmt haben
bei einer vormaligen abstimmung wieder
zurück gewinnen und dann braucht er noch
mindestens ein dutzend
labour-abgeordnete solche deren
wahlkreise für den bhc rexit gestimmt
haben und die auch vor der rache ihrer
wälder angst haben sollten sie sich
jetzt dem dinge verweigern das alles ist
eine hoch emotionale gemengelage viele
abgeordnete werden wird erst am samstag
entscheiden was sie nun tatsächlich tun
und die eigen ein einzige prognose die
man sagen kann ist dass das ergebnis
knapp wird und der samstag sehr
dramatisch danke ihnen nach london und
nach brüssel